next question comes from professor anil
seth of neuroscience
and he has a book out on consciousness
which i'll link in the description he
says ask david whether he thinks
consciousness is substrate independent
so
a silicone computer can be in principle
conscious and if so why and then as a
sub note with regard to free will i'm
always interested if they referring to
you david and anyone else if you david
realizes that the determinism versus
stochastic debate is a total red herring
um well uh okay let me
respond to these
in order i once asked um
julio tinoni
um according to his integrated conscious
is integrated information measure
which i am not a fan of let me say that
um
but in any case scott anderson is not
either and so he's got a blog post on it
um but uh according to his measure
a computer a silicon computer
whether it implements its code in
parallel or in serial
determines whether it's conscious or not
i asked him that point blank and he said
yes that determines whether it's
conscious or not
um
i'm first um responding to that aspect
of my conversation with julio before
getting to a neil um by the way i do
think anneal does some very interesting
work um
but so my reaction to that is
what is gained by defining
you can define words or if you want to
define it that's one of the liberties of
mathematics is to find things whatever
you want
it's you could define it so that julio
could say i am by definition correct
that this is consciousness my measure no
okay you can you can say that and um
that's your definition that's your
definition
but getting back to what we were talking
about last time persuasive definitions
this also gets back to surah with his
chinese rule argument which i thought
was completely vacuous
um
if you are to whatever if you are to
give a definition of consciousness
which has
any aspects to it which
if it is going to be restricted to being
a characteristic of the behavior of a
system
of the what rather than the how
then it cannot
differ for a serial or parallel computer
and that's what cyril also missed
if consciousness if thinking whatever
you want to call it
is a what rather than how
and i think it's extremely liberty
liberating as a scientist to conceive of
it that way
then it doesn't matter by definition you
just said no the how is interesting
is worthy of study but it's a different
question entirely from the what
and how these are and these should be
disentangled it is a category error to
mistake the how for the what am i to
understand that another way of saying
that is that if it's a state versus a
process
oh no is that is that false what i just
said like that's not the correct analogy
that's not what i mean to say
you right now
if behind those
baby brown eyes if behind your face
were a silicon computer
that has no consequence to the behavior
of our discussion that's what touring's
great
insight with the turing test is
and the the importance of the turing
test is not whether you're using a
teletype and things like that
is to say that as far as he
alan turing was concerned and there's a
lot to be said for this that is useful
to carve out from whatever you discuss
whenever you just want to discuss about
consciousness it is very useful to carve
out
as its own
phenomenon
call it consciousness prime call it
precon whatever you want to be where
we're just looking at the behavior of
the system
and you can have things one's in silicon
one is instead a real human being
one is instead a simulacrum that's being
controlled by somebody outside the room
looking in whatever you want
that's behaving that same way but if
it's behaving the same way you can't
tell the difference
and so for this
particular aspect of consciousness
it does not make any difference
so the tanoni is actually looking at the
other side he's focusing it's kind of
he's mixing up the two i would say
the how and the want
um
so to me the interesting thing is the
what
you first have that
then once we have that what clarified
which we don't have
we don't know how to define it even at a
behavioral level what the conscious
entity would be
or so on and so forth we can then start
to look at the how
and that's where neurobiology comes to
play which is anil's
particular
comparative advantage his specialty
and that's a completely open issue
frankly as and one that he's doing work
on
um involving things like predictive
coding blah blah blah is how do
neurobiological systems achieve it
silicon computers can achieve the same
what they're doing in a different way
and so it's a different question
then with regard to free will i'm always
interested in whether dot dot whether
they think that whether they think slash
realized so that's obviously a loaded
question
that the determinism versus
stochasticity debate is a total red
herring
um to say there's a red herring i mean
that's a extremely loaded leading
question
and i'm going to assume that it does
have that character because of uh
basically word length so to speak a
total red herring for what
um and
it's a question that cannot be answered
i would say that free will is commonly
used in common discourse is what we're
talking about yesterday persuasive
definitions
not yesterday but last time because
people commonly use free will they're
not even sure what they mean
that some people to some people it is
determinism versus stochasticity
um and that's what they mean that that's
what they mean to other people it's not
whether it's a total red herring has to
do with how you define the concept in
the first place
i don't view there as being a concept
worth discussion
i free view as being pointless come up
with your definition
your definition is going to then say
whatever you want your definition to
mean but it's your definition that's why
i'm saying we should call it what
consciousness rather than how
consciousness
just so we're clear in our definitions
i'm not going to say either one is
consciousness
i'm going to instead just make two
different definitions and say that when
people use the word consciousness they
sometimes conflate things
and free will is far more prone to that
when people use the word free will
there's actually many many flavors they
mean very many different things and they
are ultimately fighting about whose
arbitrary definition to use
and that is an exercise in futility set
your arbitrary definition and then we
can maybe or maybe not say something
um so in any case
it sounds like this question sets you
off
well it does because it's such a waste
of time
it's only it's people are debating
definitions
i don't
life's too short folks
define things wherever you want just be
clear what it is you are defining
and once we have the definition and we
don't have any
definitions have no import by themselves
it's only things we can conclude
starting from the definitions
make your definitions feel free just be
very clear what your definitions are and
then after that there might be some
interesting consequences to
investigate but to have fights about
definitions is preposterous
and that's what a lot of these fights
really are about it's just definition
pushing
let me steal man the definition i up to
just a few months ago i'm on board with
you 100
now let me steel man the definitions
point of view i was speaking to
professor jorah barnatan of mathematics
in toronto here and he was saying i was
asking him can you also in preparation
for our interview tell me which proofs
which theorems are your favorite and
then he responded and said he doesn't
like proofs and theorems and what
standard textbooks focus on he actually
thinks perhaps definitions are more
important or perhaps techniques
i thought you might be going there but
here's what i think he actually meant
he thought that coming up with
definitions that lead to a very rich set
of theorems and proofs that that is the
key to being i mean here is my putting
words in his mouth to being a successful
and important and do important work in
mathematics is to first come up with the
very fruitful definitions i fully agree
that but that is not what people who are
arguing about free will are arguing
about they're not saying for which
definition of free will
and he wasn't actually either your
professor he wasn't saying which
definition
of
um parallel
should i adopt
he was saying no what's important is if
i put together the words in a certain
way
and then i call them what i call them
doesn't matter
but those set of words put together in
this way we'll call it a alpha b beta
we've just defined a alpha b beta if i
can use a alpha b beta to prove a whole
bunch of fruitful things that's a good
definition
these people instead are saying what
should a alpha b beta mean
which is backwards
so that professor um he was saying that
it's not the words not the clothes don't
make the man it's not the words that
you're draping this with that matter is
whatever this is
and here people are saying well i've got
my words first and i'm going to fight
with you about whether um they actually
mean this or they mean that
it's it's useless it's it's backwards
it's not only anti-scientific i would
say it's anti-intellectual almost
now for the sake of playing the devil's
advocate let me know what you think
about this now when we're not talking
about mathematics something that's
specifically well defined when we come
up with a definition
it works somewhat akin to this we have
an intuitive notion of some concept and
it's ambiguous and then we give it a
name and we usually give it a name by
pointing to different objects that
satisfy what we think is that intuitive
definition so for example with life
we'll say the couch behind you is not
alive you're alive the beetle is alive
the fire is alive
let's say minus 3000 years ago and then
there's other people arguing about that
well the fire is not alive but i do
agree david is alive and i also agree
that the couch is not alive so we have
these volutinous feelings of amorphous
balls and we're trying to see okay well
what's the intersection between us which
one captures what we're trying to say
most which one captures the most
relevant
concepts so that's why there are
disagreements about the definition we're
trying to figure out we're arguing about
what the entries in the oed should be
there's an entry in the oed for life and
what should it be the oxford english
dictionary
and so for example on that particular
topic
people do define life as a bit
and i always and the question is well
how should i define that bit if they
want to always be it's alive or it's not
alive what's how do we define what one
or the other means
so this is a other work of mine earlier
in my career i did with a fellow club
bill mccrady and others have picked it
up since um
so
my reaction to that was that this is
silly definition plugging come up with
your definition and whatever to say
something israel is not alive is silly
um at a minimum if you're talking about
biological organisms
it's not going to be just a single bit
it's going to be actually at least a
real number and well actually it's going
to be a vector we'll actually know it's
going to be some much more higher
dimensional thing
it's not going to be life is a bit
clever life is some
other mathematical structure and here's
one that we happen to come up with that
actually turned out to be somewhat
fruitful another topic of research i
want to work with
you know what a fractal is i assume okay
so i take the m the magnifying glass and
i'm magnifying that microscope but i
keep seeing the same thing
let's take that magnifying glass that
microscope
put it on your skin
as we keep running up the power
we go down to the level where we're
seeing now individual cells now we start
going with you know within the cells and
so on
the images in that
microscope keep changing
you are not self-similar you are self
dissimilar
the patterns in you
are very different from one another at
each different scale
in fact
that seems to be true of almost all
systems that are alive
it is not true
of almost all systems that are not alive
moreover this self-dissimilarity is a
way to give nuance and structure
to the form of the life
because you can actually be looking at
how is it that the patterns of at each
scale are related to one another you've
got an entire matrix
and so this we called it
self-dissimilarity
and we were very careful not to say it's
living or not
and we simply say actually i think we
verse this effect
any system that does have
self-dissimilarity high
self-dissimilarity
is almost by definition going to be very
interesting
and some people might say it's actually
a complex system
but we again we don't want to be
selling it with these definitions we're
just going to simply say it's
self-dissimilarity and we put it out
there as a proposal to the research
community that they shouldn't be
spending all this effort in trying to
figure out what should the definition of
this bit living or not living be
that that's fruitless and it's just
going to be an internal wars that never
are going to end up
being rich in the sense of definitions
that your mathematics professor was
thinking
but let's instead be thinking about the
self-dissimilarity of different systems
because why would you think that an
interesting living system might be
self-dissimilar in the first place so
it's not just that we can notice
phenomenologically
that living systems are all
self-dissimilar whereas non-living
systems like mountain tops and so on are
so similar we can actually ask why might
that be the case
and so here's a
interesting proposal that i have not yet
time to investigate
what if biological systems this is
somewhat along the lines of the things
that carl fristen is interested in
what if biological systems
had to as a for for um and also for that
mayor donald hoffman had to as an
evolutionary imperative
extract the maximal computational bang
out of a given physical body buck
how might they do that well one thing
you can think of doing is distribute
different parts of that computation to
different spatial locations in that body
and that's what systems do biological
systems to a large degree they have the
computations that are going on in your
brain being a different part of you from
the computations that are going on in
your kidney for example you've been the
competition's been distributed but you
might also not only want to distribute
the computation across different
positions but also across scales
there might be different and there are
if you think about it different
computations being done by the cells in
you
compared to the computations being done
by the organs in you
moreover these computations being done
at the different scales are actually
communicating with one another
so you can imagine that as an
evolutionary imperative biological
systems would be driven
to want to distribute the computations
that they do
across their different scales as well as
their different spatial position part
positions within them which would then
lead us to start to think about what
does it even mean
to distribute computation across scales
what are the general features of such
systems
and it would lead you down a research
path which i've not had time to go
but it would lead you down a fruitful
research path to in fact
um uh refute and and and dispute and
and
um
avow no
to the concept that life can be reduced
to a bit
but we if we start by saying that this
exercise is an exercise in futility
that instead we want to come up with um
not a definition that's reducible to a
bit you are or you are not
but rather look at this much more
nuanced structure
it might lead us in much more fruitful
research directions it might be a much
more useful definition
in the sense of that mathematics
professor you're you are describing
before
now if you can answer this one quickly
because this isn't a side about what you
said you mentioned that
it may not be a bit it could be a vector
now i see how it could not be a bit it
could be a real number but i don't see
how is it that this dissimilarity
measure could be a vector like r2 r3 et
cetera ah so here's what i can do
i take that microscope this is an
exercise that we've actually did on
various some image data sets for example
and we applied it to things like the
logistic dynamics and so on and so forth
um take that microscope that's i'm
getting distributions of of the visual
images of the patterns at different
scales
these are now going to be distributions
over the pixel pattern within the
microscope's field of view
now i can there's many measures from uh
machine learning probability theory
information theory for saying how
different two distributions are
so this way i can say
for any one of the following say 10
scales
how different
is the distribution over images at those
two scales so i'm comparing scales
magnification two times a modification
seven times
those scales have associated
distributions over images
and look at how different those
distributions over images are the scale
two times and seven times that gives me
a real number
i then look at it for another pair of
magnifications that gives me another
real number
so in this so in essence what you were
seeing that this pat this set of
of differences between distributions
at the different scales
can be wound up into one actually it's a
matrix because you're putting in the two
scales
that i'm comparing into these elements
of these matrix so for if you give me
two scales i'll give you a real number
it's actually more rich than a vector as
a full matrix a symmetric matrix
um
yes this particular case is symmetric
exactly so